some clark county employees as well as
former county employees say the
government center is just not safe
at least 50 people have gathered to file
a lawsuit alleging
they've been exposed to toxins in the
building it is a story the 8 news now
i-team first broke and vanessa murphy is
live
with what is an exclusive interview
vanessa
brian lawyers say they've uncovered a
cancer cluster
they blame exposure to toxic chemicals
and they say the clark county government
center
should be shut down they point to the
number of clark county employees getting
sick
some even dying and they say it's no
coincidence
it's heart-wrenching um it's several
people that i knew
acquainted with are actually very ill
and candidly
might not make it so it is a personal
thing for me las vegas local craig
mueller says he remembers the days of
the union pacific railroad as a child
today some land the railroad used is the
site of the clark county government
center
mueller says employees there have gotten
sick because of
toxic chemicals the railroad left behind
he's representing 50 plaintiffs in a
lawsuit
i've got people dying of bladder cancer
ovarian cancer
uterine cancer pancreatic cancer brain
cancer st louis attorney lindsey dibbler
is also on the case
the the number of plaintiffs that are in
this lawsuit
or is really the tip of the iceberg
their research dates back to the early
1900s
according to this newspaper clipping by
1952
a tar pit at the site was a known hazard
the railroad then set fire to the pit
and its waste materials
by the 70s that was covered in dirt the
lawsuit also points to several nearby
spills
numerous documents which followed refer
to contamination
and recommendations for more testing and
cleanup it was clear that the city knew
about the contamination that the county
knew about the contamination
and they also knew that the testing and
the
remedial efforts that they were taking
were deficient
still the government center was built in
the 90s
dibbler says workers immediately began
to feel sick and reported it but
supervisors brushed them off
the lawsuit alleges recent testing
confirms the building
is not safe we have found polychlorial
biphenyls
dioxins heavy metals literally a witch's
brew
of toxic materials were found
in the ground around the building and in
the ventilation system
the city of las vegas clark county and
several big companies like monsanto are
named in the lawsuit
you're going against giants here
what's your response and your point is
yeah i i yes i i'm
yes you i work for a judge and he said
told me something that
has always stuck with me in the practice
of law you go where the facts
and the law take you
you can see they are confident about
this case i did reach out to the
defendants
named in the lawsuit clark county and
the city of las vegas say they don't
comment on pending litigation the
lawyers say
they've heard from more workers at clark
county who are fearful of retaliation
if they do become part of this lawsuit
they believe many more people have been
affected throughout the years
we have a phone number for them at
8newsnow.com
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now